висоти пташиного польоту це місце ще не надто схоже
на українську кремнієву долину.
Водночас і від занедбаних територій, які були тут останні 20 років,
нині вже майже нічого не залишилося.
У 2016 році на 25 гектарах
колишнього Київського мотоциклетного заводу
почали зводити перший в Україні інноваційний парк.
Аби зберегти автентичність промислового гіганта,
50-метрову трубу-димар перетворили на витвір сучасного мистецтва.
Дві будівлі заводу залишили, змінивши їхній зовнішній вигляд і внутрішню структуру.
Тепер у них - школа і бізнес-кампус.
Нам більше не потрібні великі фабрики,
особливо не потрібні вони в центрі міста,
але нам потрібен простір для інноваційних людей,
щоб створювати нові компанії, нові види бізнесу.
Іноді здається, що буде дешевше просто зруйнувати те, що є,
і побудувати щось нове.
Але я вірю, що є реальна цінність у минулому.
Ми маємо використовувати це минуле,
щоб створити нові речі, які нам потрібні.
Сьогодні у Юнітсіті  працюють понад 100 компаній-резидентів.
Здебільшого це стартапи та представники креативних індустрій.
Марина Черниш працює в міжнародній компанії,
яка займається тестуванням та виготовленням прототипів продуктів.
Її офіс-лабораторія переїхав до Юнітсіті
одним із перших.
Каже, не в останню чергу через історію цього місця.
Саме ця будівля, в якій ми знаходимося, - це старий цех заводу,
мені здається, що атмосфера того, що
ми створюємо зі старого щось нове,
воно надає наснаги...
Аби побудувати інфраструктуру з п’яти бізнес-кампусів з офісами,
кафе, школою програмування
та спортивним комплексом,
інвестори витратили майже 100 мільйонів доларів.
Проте це скоріше виняток, коли йдеться про ревіталізацію ,
тобто відновлення функціональності колишніх промислових районів Києва.
Нині, за даними міської влади, у столиці
майже 9 тисяч гектарів територій
зайняті занедбаними промисловими
чи комунально-складськими приміщеннями.
Це площа близько 13 тисяч футбольних полів.
У Києва навіть є свій "іржавий пояс" - так називають промзони,
що простягаються вздовж Дніпра.
Вони могли б стати креативним осередком міста.
Але на заваді цьому стоїть з одного боку різна форма власності промислових об’єктів,
з іншого - відсутність законодавчого підґрунтя
та підтримки з боку міської влади.
Місто системно не співпрацює з людьми,
що займаються ревіталізацією промислових зон.
Я, як людина, що керувала Unit, хочу сказати,
що ми з містом йшли паралельними шляхами.
Але системної допомоги не отримували,
Я думаю, що приблизно те саме відбувається
зі всіма промисловими зонами.
Системним програм з підтримки інвесторів,
що інвестують в промзони, я не знаю.
Дедалі частіше на місці промзон зводять сучасні житлові комплекси.
Так вже за кілька років на території колишнього
Київського авторемонтного заводу виростуть багатоповерхівки.
Доти ж компанія-забудовник дозволила
оселитися в одній із будівель
колишнього заводу кільком організаціям,
які займаються дослідженням міського простору.
Тепер тут щоденно працюють над проектами перетворення столиці
в комфортне місто,
проводять вечірки й презентації.
Анастасія Пономарьова,
одна із резидентів КАРЗ-12 пояснює:
будівлі, які на перший погляд здаються непридатними для роботи чи творчості,
насправді ховають в собі колосальні переваги.
Тут просто банально більше свободи,
ти можеш робити тут те, що не можеш робити в звичайному офісі,
ти можеш робити тут більше,
ніж можеш робити в звичайній галереї
тут можна робити гучні події вночі, тут можна змінити колір стін.
І це людям подобається,
їм хочеться експериментувати
бути необмеженими якимись правилами.
Втім, ревіталізація має безліч ризиків і підводних каменів.
В Україні, на відміну від європейських країн,
проекти трансформації здебільшого мають статус неформальних.
Вони не отримують державних інвестицій чи гарантій.
Це означає, що в будь-який момент вже відновлений простір
може бути виселений чи забудований.
Про непередбачувані ризики ревіталізації міського простору
з власного досвіду знають засновники платформи культурних ініціатив Ізоляція.
У 2010 році вона стала першим масштабним проектом такого типу в Україні.
На території колишнього заводу ізоляційних матеріалів у Донецьку
блаштували творчі майстерні, проводили літературні фестивалі
й виставки всесвітньовідомих митців.
У 2014 році Ізоляцію захопили бойовики самопроголошеної ДНР,
і платформа переїхала до Києва, де почала все з нуля.
В оновленому форматі IZONE оселилася в одній з будівель
діючого судноремонтного заводу.
Михайло Глибокий пригадує: аби отримати приміщення в оренду,
довелося довго пояснювати, чим саме буде займатися платформа.
Зараз, наприклад, у завода дуже багато орендарів,
багато різних бізнесів підтягнулися,
і ситуація, у порівнянні з 2014 роком дуже змінилася.
Тепер тут черга велика людей, які хочуть
знімати тут простори і щось розвивати.
Зараз це стало дуже популярним.
Після двох успішних проектів, реалізованих на заводах,
Михайло Глибокий як ніхто може оцінити
потенціал процесу ревіталізації міст.
Він впевнений: промислові території і приміщення можуть бути використані в багатьох містах,
особливо на сході України та в прифронтовій зоні.
там можна використовувати ці приміщення,
для того, щоб створювати на базі них освітні програми,
для того, щоб люди могли знаходити роботу.
В умовній Авдіївці можуть працювати на замовника в Нью-Йорку
і отримувати гроші на рівні світовому.
За останні п’ять років успішна трансформація індустріального середовища
в креативні центри дійсно стала трендом всеукраїнського масштабу.
У Києві, Львові, Харкові, Одесі, Маріуполі та малих містах різних регіонів
на місці колишніх заводів і фабрик з’являються  арт-простори,
книгарні, івент-зони і коворкінги.
Анастасія Пономарьова каже, подібні проекти -
це набагато більше, ніж освоєння приміщень і територій.
Цінність їх у тому, що вони можуть стати
центром з розуміння багатьох поколінь, багатьох смаків
об’єднати населення, яке необхідно об’єднувати.
У проекті генерального плану розвитку Києва та його приміської зони
на наступні п'ять років площу промислових
та комунально-складських територій
хочуть таки скоротити до 5,5 тисяч гектарів.
Про конкретні культурні ініціативи наразі, щоправда, не йдеться.
Аби занедбані землі приносили прибуток у бюджет і робочі місця,
на них пропонують в першу чергу
звести громадські та житлові центри,
а також нові технопарки.